[Musique]
bon alors pas mal l'afab en fin d'année
là c'était parti de regarder loin
regarder des chaînes du corps et du
corps jamais n'oubliez pas un cheveux
attachés et h au bar
je sais pas de cheveux attachés à ce que
j'attaque plus je veux tu en voilà
isabelle pardon
[Musique]
or tous parce qu'ils n'y avait de
chances que le cabrel que j'ai reçue à
quel jeu n'a pas de nostalgie la pêche
si maintenant elle est habile shit
capable de séchage contrats dans les
devises
mais sa main droite mais la bouche
sur tout le web ça c'est pas tout cas
vrai ça mais quand midam c'est un grand
monsieur
la bulle échelonnant est la plus apte à
jouer mais c'est des fringues transforme
en pvc pas mes fans ballon prend du loir
de mon papa ma cabane au fond du jardin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'action d'arrondir une tour
la chanteuse a changé mais c'est juste
qu'il me pousse à faire des vagues un
peu courant de la nuit ferment les yeux
et les et comme si j'avais le prix de
leur mère juste avant ce moule et vous
me dites pas que c'est moi regarde jour
se lève dans la tendresse ma vie je veux
vivre comme dans un rêve tout ce que
j'aime h2o besoin de rien envie de toi
j'avais envie de personnes si j'en fais
toujours trop gens trouvent des coûts 15
tu marques tu m'avais fait pascal obispo
vachement kto par l'aipac je crois que
ton mec était apte à combattre en guise
a pas deux comme ralph andretta combat
par ko à la base'' garde wallon
[Musique]